the repatriation of dozens of families
with suspected links to the islamic
state terror group has about fear in the
iraqi city of mosul
around 300 people from 90 families are
returning to iraq
from syria's al hall refugee camp it's
the first repatriation under a deal
struck then between the iraqi government
and the u.s led coalition in the region
mostly may recall was captured by isil
back in 2014
and held under that brutal regime for
three years
now residents say they don't want any of
the jihadis to return
we condemn this and will not accept
their return they are the reason for the
destruction
whether we want them or not their return
will bring destruction and problems to
the city
and the country generally this area was
not revealed serviced or even
compensated
no electricity we are suffering from
lack of services
the government today does not fully
control the cases of returning displaced
isil families this reality has been
forced on the people of mosul as a way
of getting rid of isil families
we as families of the martyrs reject
their presence in the districts we live
in
the state is now insisting on returning
and integrating these families
but it's impossible to forget the blood
of the martyrs just to please the
government
and isil families
they destroyed us attacked our homes
orphaned our children
took our beautiful young one sally here
he was taken from me
this is my son he had a child his wife
was widowed because of isil
my daughter and her husband died because
of isil my son was killed
by isil
you